we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
ah
here we are folks we're back i know last
week was a sad and somber one but we're
here i got a hawaiian shirt on sam's
wearing sweatpants the beer jew is
cooking
we're rolling
i like i like the outfit thank you thank
you i'm wearing sweatpants too
i uh i feel like it's still hot out i'm
like when's this summer gonna end so i
throw in a hawaiian i like the hawaiian
is i don't think i've ever seen you in
one i wore one here this exact shirt
yeah yeah all right but i got to pay
attention
they breathe they breathe yeah it's
weird when people say it
what can breathe a shirt a wine
yeah
yeah that's true i almost made a
horrible racial joke but uh let me think
what's the guy saying from staten island
uh i can't breathe what's that uh what
else can breathe
sheets can breathe you know yeah these
this comforter really breathes yeah wine
can breathe yeah i can't breathe when my
mom nags me
do i tell her yeah norm can't breathe
that was my segway oh sorry norm you
know you knew this is how good the comic
norm was is that like no comics made
jokes about his death that's true i saw
one and it was pretty great what was it
it was uh
man who would have thought artie lang
would outlive nor mcdonald's yeah and i
was like that's [ __ ] great we all
thought that yeah that was arimanus
funny guy
damn that is well you know what's crazy
is artie's like
i listen to artie's tribute to norm you
know he did a little special and it's
like the first time i've heard his voice
and already sounded great so you're like
[ __ ] i hope already gets better yeah
yeah he's still lucid and funny and all
that i just he looks like hell but he's
still
with it thank god do you think about
norm it's crazy that norm would just go
on
these
late night shows
unwell like you re-watched some of this
stuff and it's like chadwick bozeman
when you're like oh we had no idea that
he was just showing up to do all this
work feeling like dude
i can't imagine that i know you get a
quick neck you're like i'm canceling the
wedding
oh i thought about that like if i had
cancer and i was on the road my opener
would be like you better laugh cancer
that would be my opener right yeah he
was stoic he totally hid it he didn't
want the the glory ah [ __ ] it you know
i'm i got cancer but i was i've listened
to like
900 hours of norm stuff just to mourn
and
commemorate commemorate commemorate is
that something sure yeah yeah i always
say the commemorative coins
on uh like fox news these weird old
people gifts they get the plates
america weird yeah can you imagine being
happy like dad we got you that george
washington coin here and i and you're
like you mean a quarter yeah give me a
[ __ ] you got me a quarter yeah what are
we doing here yeah you got me a quarter
the commemorative coins speaking of coin
who's that [ __ ] guzzler out there on the
beach every saturday with the metal
detector that guy's still around yeah i
was just in florida i saw that guy it's
so weird i know get a job you have your
hobo but do they ever find good [ __ ]
never you better off going to a pawn
shop or something
yeah it's crazy it's a weird hobby right
it's a weird sad hobby but it's like
it's like a scratch-off ticket you never
know holy [ __ ] the beard jew comes
through with a short sleeve shirt
so this is a mojito yep
what is the garnish here is that basil
mint basil cheese
i'm a real idiot
uh what is that carbonara uh in the
drink uh yeah what is that marijuana
yeah wow that's a beautiful looking
mojito
mohit i'm not a big mojito guy they're a
little sweet for me but you make you're
so good at making drinks i bet i'll like
it yes i took the sweetness off for this
one you mega man's man's cocktail yeah
yeah i think it's like the kind of like
the last days of summer you want to
commemorate them and uh here yeah that's
why i got the shirt on too i love it i
love it i like it by the way i don't
know has anyone ever thought about this
the two only two groups that like super
sweet drinks
women and black people they're the only
two everyone else hates them
some men like them you see do you see
dudes with mountain dew and i don't know
i mean look i met a lot of comedy clubs
and i got the black table over here i'm
like that's a lot of blue drinks on a
tray
blue drink with fruit and umbrellas and
all that i'm like you're the toughest
guy in here they're keeping that
electric lemonade going that's uh yes
yes exactly i will tell you i remember
mike yard who's a really funny cop funny
and uh and a great dude tough guy too oh
yeah i believe east new york and been
shot
in there yeah like tough dude and i
remember one night he ordered a bailey's
irish cream on the rocks
and i was like ooh like i kind of gave
him some [ __ ] for it he goes i could
still kick your ass i was like yeah yeah
but afterwards you'll be celebrating
with the bailey's irish cream
but yes you could still kick my ass mike
without a question that is a silly
argument it's like hey dude you're
wearing a women's underwear well i could
beat your ass but yeah you still wearing
women's underwear that's that's the
point but all right yeah you're just
ripping your friends yeah let's try this
here here mazel
whoa good cleaning nice glass
these are thick glasses
oh my god that's incredible dude you
have got a gift
this is [ __ ] magical
tell them how to make it there bear so
basically it's just uh
technically it's 1.5 ounce um
white rum we're using bacardi today but
we also have uh mount gay eclipse which
is also very nice mountain gay
you want to go for like uh a silver roof
you don't want to be at the bottom of
that mountain
[Laughter]
that mountain's broke back
and then it's just some uh lime juice
some simple syrup and uh shake it up
muddle the mint in there shake it up and
uh top with soda water wow
i've had a lot of mojitos in my day and
that one is the tops best
i'm not a big
mojito guy not really no you knew we
were drinking today and i didn't and you
were you were pretty excited for this
one well i knew if the beer jew was
cooking it up it would be something
special and this is special meats
that's why i'm going to drink it slow
[Laughter]
yeah
shouldn't drive
um but yeah yeah wow that is great man
uh
you make it just right because you're
right a lot of there's a lot of people
lean on that that sweet that what is
that that squeezy thing you put in there
the syrup the syrup simple syrup yeah
yes scissors that's basically you're
covering up like bad ingredients but
they do that
like bad sushi restaurants i hear like
say if you're in a bad place don't order
the spicy tuna because they're covering
up old tuna
that's what i say when i haven't
showered i'm like it's a little spicy
sorry there misses spicy crabs
[Music]
yeah that's a salmon skin
you know what i hate is the epidemic
with the with the sushi now and this
wasn't around back when i was banging is
the uh the gooey
saucy
aioli [ __ ] on top they have to put that
mayonnaise
i think they went too far i feel like
we're fat americans so they're like
gotta give them more sauce gotta give
them more like give me the goods we'll
just get that you're getting especially
uh the special rolls just get the
regular oh maybe that's my because i
like a special roll yeah like a special
rule all right they're good but you're
right if they if they go a little if
it's too wet you're like what are we
doing yes yeah she's like the opposite
of a woman if it's too wet we got a
problem
i don't know i'd rather wet than dry
my girlfriend's so wet the other day i
had to put her in rice
all right that's my update of rodney
uh
you know what i go back on that premise
i was trying to spin something quickly
if you're too wet it's pretty good
pretty good i said opposite of a woman
there you go that's right there you go
you got it yeah if somebody did a
there's so much norm stuff out there
that somebody did a norm to rodney late
nights oh wow and you could see the
idealized idolize rodney and you can see
the influence like ronnie would come out
banging on the couch and then they cut
the norm banging on the couch and you're
like whoa i see it
it's really weird yeah this is a weird
criticism of norm and i mean this is a
compliment
he was so much better on the couch than
he just did pure stand up on the show
yeah because norm was doing such a high
level of comedy that he needed a guy to
set him up interesting i think i mean he
was doing this
conan called it like a high wire act yes
and that's kind of what it felt like you
need a guy to be like what are you doing
like brother knew how to be the straight
man right like what carson and
dangerfield had conan and norm had
wow that's a great call even more so i'd
say because carson really just had to be
like just set up rodney yeah nor conan
had to kind of be like what do you talk
like he had to like really he god had to
make it like a buddy comedy exactly he
obviously loved norm and wanted norm to
keep going but you have to be like
you're crazy nuts you know but it's all
part of the show that's what people
don't get this is all entertainment like
people go what's wrong with norm he's
doing the thing he's he's being funny
well there was the one where he said
give us the two uh 2006 interview jon
stewart
and norm
norm is making a joke about the
crocodile hunter who has just died and
he's like that guy had a hard time
getting life insurance he goes yeah i'm
a crocodile hunter you know
there he goes it was made the 44 the
ripe old age of 44 as a crocodile hunter
and like and then he gets killed by a
little fruity fish that's what he said
like they must have been furious like
who killed him frank they're like nah
some little fish man he was so good at
comedy like you know when they say you
know all the you have to know the rules
to break them yeah he had that down
because he had a weekend update joke
where johnny cochran you know in the oj
trial put on a knit cap and it was like
showing that it it couldn't fit oj
because it was too big on his head and
he goes or as oj refers to it my lucky
stabbing hat
and it's just so it's like funny
concentrated like that the orange juice
the frozen stuff there's no adding to it
there's no water mixed in it's just
man that's funny you're so right like he
would he would just it's almost like he
would just say the thing like yeah this
wasn't a joke like how we sometimes
forget sometimes you see a joke
simplified and like oh that's the joke
right but when when there's fat on it
you're like ah he cut out all the fat it
was you're right it's funny concentrate
yeah yeah he had it uh concentration
camp i mean he's just uh
on another level and we could do an hour
i just wanted to say three things yeah
check out norm on this dennis miller uh
appearances are unbelievable yeah yeah
that one's great uh and he's talking
about spade loves [ __ ] and all that it's
great and then he's he's great on adam
carolla's show where they break down
kenny rogers songs kenny rogers has some
dark songs and they break them down oh
and i had another one oh and conan does
a tribute to him and it's [ __ ]
touching how he's like get norm here we
need norm and they're like he doesn't
want to come in and he didn't realize
he's just dying of cancer but they're
like why won't norm come in what the
[ __ ] and that's what you learn like
everybody's going through something he's
like does norm not like me is something
going on you know so
norm he said norm was the number one
request when conan started a podcast
like by a mile like why haven't you had
norm on and
i was wondering what would have been as
good though because you i
the crowd really yeah what made norm so
good is that he just didn't
he knew how to like
he worked them in a way where it was
like almost like a boxer like oh yeah it
was
yeah he was he was
probably the best panel guest ever
probably cuz it was so damn
unpredictable yeah like rodney was great
joe great joke but norm was like i don't
know what he's going to say i don't know
where he's going to go
yeah it was rodney
i mean i'm not taking rodney is a
[ __ ] genius oh yeah rodney the
greatest one of the greatest
but you know damn yeah we got somber
again here ah all right we got a lot to
talk about stuff it's a lot to talk
about tough loss wow one more for norman
yes here here my hero
i really do see your influence oh man
it's huge huge and like conan had
another great point and i'll leave it
alone he goes
norm got fired for making jokes about a
murderer and then he went on the espys
and he made jokes about these athletes
who were kind of pieces of [ __ ] and he
got scolded for it and he's everybody's
like in comedy's like i'm a hero i'm
against racism i'm against homophobia
he's like we all agree with that
this guy got in trouble
and actually was a hero like he was
actually pushing against and got in
trouble for it that's a hero well the
espy's it wasn't i mean he was making
fun of oj again right he's made kind of
like he was making fun of uh jerry jones
he was he would attack
he he had a [ __ ] meter and he would
yeah people that he thought were getting
away with something yeah yeah yeah
exactly so but then he got in trouble he
got fired for like one of the great
comedy jobs can you imagine getting
fired now from snl from making fun of a
murderer exactly like oh hey what's the
equivalent like robert durst is going to
trial you know like you can't you can't
make fun of robert durst yeah yeah he's
friends with the the head guy like which
would you like well that could be again
but yeah
that's true
now how spineless i mean they were
spineless in like another direction then
now they're spineless and like they're
always living in fear but usually it's a
fear that protects them now it's like
don't don't [ __ ] with me right
right great point so true that the fear
is still there it's just changed
directions yeah interesting all right
all right sorry we we can go down to
normal rabbit hole every week for the
rest of this you got that right but yeah
i'm showing it to the lady who who's
bored by everything and she's like
howling it's so fun to watch yeah he's a
beast beast but you're you're kind of
right the panel is really where he he
shined
shone shine shine yeah well he uh
i had watched another one it was like
nick schwartz and sam oh
i saw that one two closeted
oh my so many good oh that closet a gay
thing what a brilliant twist on that
yeah he's it was great
damn
it's also cool you can bill burr's got a
tribute conan's got a tribute saggy like
all these people already lang they all
just directed him in dirty work that's
right that's right i always forget that
saggett directed that one mm-hmm
so funny the guy the america's dad the
squeaky cleaniest guy of all time
is the filthiest guy on the planet you
know how tall he is
six four seven you got it six four i
opened all the [ __ ] in
vancouver years years ago sag a very
nice guy yeah
i've heard he's a sweet sweet guy but
his act is literally like jizz in my ass
[ __ ] a kid it was like actually i didn't
open form it was like uh
a theater gala type thing so he hosted
it so i went on after him actually and
it was all oh man look at that geez
sorry
we started taking about talking about
sagging all the holy things in here fell
apart
all the wholesome pictures we got can we
get rid of that one what the hell is
that i don't know what that is either
yeah tell these fans to start sending in
some some knickknacks so we can uh
yeah we got so yeah
remember gotham studios if you want to
send us a booze if you want to send us
you know
stuff for the studio
uh yeah please please send it over i
mean yeah it's like a [ __ ] uh
red red robin in here you know we got we
have a
peter she did a great job with the
studio i'm just saying uh it looks like
rochester in here where you're from
we gotta get out of rochester all right
let's get back to mount gay uh where
were you this weekend i was in philly
hey i was in millersville and then
philly had uh
had about my buddy shafi hosting the
millersville gary veter featuring and
then it was it was a two-person show
me and a boy two morose jews for the
price of one brother really great time
it was it was great yeah you got little
jew big jew yeah it was fun man we had a
great time that's great how about you
where were you one of my favorite club i
love philly as a city you ever walk
around that written house beautiful
beautiful it's like pretty girls and the
fountain and the it's so lush and all
these cool restaurants around there it's
great history because i are walking
through the park and there's a guy
playing uh music he's playing elton john
on the guitar and we just walked by and
as we walked by he goes sam how were the
shows this weekend whoa
that's awesome that was pretty cool
that's great the artist stopped to talk
to the artist it was nice yeah and then
you're like i'm not dipping you
but no one has cash anymore that's
become a hard game good point i guess
someone put a venmo there that's true
but who's gonna open their phone that's
the whole thing yeah yeah i i i had the
guy uh you ever have the guy outside a
chase bank doing the door open you're
like all they give you is 20s i know
what do you want me to do here the
ticklish i got no i could write you a
call
too oh i mean it's a bad system that's a
bad system i mean you might as well be
that ice cream guy with the ch
you know like you got to make you got to
make change here buddy well that's a
tough thing if you're if you're homeless
now like we're going way digital digital
yeah you know so uh
that's if i was a stripper my name would
be a cash app yeah
just put it into the stage
yeah
paypal everybody
oh yeah yeah this is like in the friend
zone
so good once again
and you look fresh you look a
non-hungover for the first time in here
like the hair slicked back look at that
i got a haircut because uh i've been
working seven days a week so i gotta do
something to look not ridiculous yeah
women told a woman a woman told me that
if a guy has a little bit of shine in
his hair they go nuts yeah yeah because
it means that they're together exactly
and it goes back to that old school
draper thing you know like you gotta you
gotta you're a man
it's funny women want like the draper
type but they don't want the draper type
all right well they want don draper but
they don't want what comes with don
draper right
right yeah that's true it's kind of like
craving you know a cheesecake it's like
but you don't want that after effect
yeah i think that's how life is i mean
look you want to bang carmen electra but
you don't want to you don't have uh you
don't want to be damned with her no yeah
that's true
now i would love to be dennis roberts i
think in the 90s i want to be dennis
rodman i think now
you put on a wedding dress for a photo
shoot i don't think so
but that was rod rodman was like
he was like [ __ ] with people he was
great that's how great robin is he's not
even trans and he's like i'm gonna dress
with as a woman for the attention it'll
be yeah it'll be a thing but that just
raises the question obviously younger
people and people in the know and the
media have to push boundaries i'm trans
now or i'm uh whatever
it's got to go the other way because if
you go so far this way eventually
someone's gonna go i have no tattoos and
we're gonna go damn
yeah you know what i mean
it's gotta go like somebody's gonna show
up in a business suit and a job and no
piercings and be religious so we're
gonna go this guy's a [ __ ] rock star
yeah you're right eventually there's
gonna be like a census thing where
someone's like he she or they and
they're like she and they're like hmm
yeah whoa a little edgy yeah interesting
as a woman yeah
it's gotta it's all cyclical
yeah
for sure you're right it is one of those
things i used to have a bit about this
but it was like how
if you're a guy and you like get your
eyebrows done your friends are like
you're a [ __ ] but if you become a woman
they're like you're a hero
like how it's like it's you got to go
all out you can't you can't give like a
little bit
yeah like it's like if you get a haircut
right sometimes like like we're not
[ __ ] but if you get a haircut and
you go to the comedy cellar someone's
like ooh someone got a haircut yep they
just start tearing you to shreds it's so
true or the worst one they go i see you
got a haircut and they don't say if it's
good or bad they just like you got a
haircut yeah
yeah you know what i never got uh oh no
somebody has a great bid but i can't
think of who has the bit and i feel bad
because i want to give him credit but
some guy did great but he's like i got i
got broken up with and then you walk
around new york all you see is men and
women making out everywhere and you're
like ah geez what the [ __ ] get a room
god damn it get out of here and then i
saw a gay couple making out i'm like
good for you
that's kind of how it is like with
certain groups you got to be more
supportive
yeah it's a funny take there's so many
new couples in new york cause it's a
city that you just see so much pda
i know also that it's also like a
vacation spot destination for people so
that's also like we're on vacation we're
happy true true you also see the
unraveling you also see the unraveling
yeah you see both yeah nothing i mean
i've seen so many girls crying on the
subway platform just like trying to hide
it and you're like after you talk to him
yeah i did my act
but yeah it's uh it's true i think it
was we're just out of our apartments our
apartments are the size of a
beard juice dick so you got to get out
it's so small and then
you know
i'd say if his dick is uh 500 square
feet he's doing all right that's a good
point that's a good point
yeah but no
kitchen his dick's got a kitchenette
catches at the back
uh yeah girl you take off your pants
your dick's got a walk-in closet that's
pretty cool
now get back in it
um
yeah yeah philly though at least no
flight what did you drive there we drove
it was yeah that was one of those hotels
we were like anytime there's a wedding
in the hotel you're like i think i could
do a little bit better than this hotel
next time oh yeah
it's like i hate when i hate being that
guy but i'm like dude they're screaming
on my floor at three in the morning i'm
like can i can someone they're like it
will send up security wow you're the guy
now you're the shut these people down
guys i think karen alert
come on what happened you just let them
[ __ ] go wild
put on a podcast leave the kid let the
kids be young and and fun yeah by the
way they were my age they weren't
getting
the wedding they're they're drunk vito
was furious too i'm happy i'm with old
jew man energy
he was like this is unacceptable i'm
like it is unacceptable you know picture
video in a card with a pipe and a little
leather-bound book like oh he was
furious he's also he's a dad so he just
gets up at 8 30.
he just gets at 8 30 because he gets up
at 8 30. sure and then he's texting me
at like noon he's like breakfast i'm
starving please you can eat with that
yeah right right but he wants that you
want that road lunch
yeah um
wait were you i mean it's already over
so were you at the sonesta i was yeah
that's where i was too not great
it's a little
cheesy down there it's a little night
clubby yeah it's not great not great you
know what i don't care for here's a
peeve
ruth chris's steakhouse what a stew see
how hard it was for me you just say
right now get a real [ __ ] name for
your steakhouse well i got a little i
gotta push back because it's from new
orleans okay well the stupid names it is
a stupid name but here's the here's the
rub
dry rub but
ruth was this crazy old coos who worked
under the thumb of her husband he opened
a steakhouse he said they have like five
kids he walks out on the family yeah
back in the day when you could do that
and there was no facebook trail and he
walks out of the family so this poor
lady is in the back
cooking up steaks alone with her with
her children like trying to keep the
restaurant alive because they got no
other income they're freaking out so
she grows it into this giant huge like
five-star steakhouse all the big big
wigs are eating there and everything and
then she makes a chain another chain
it's this insane story of like a you
know independent woman who got screwed
over who makes it big and it was called
chris's steakhouse and she's like it's
ruth's chris [ __ ] i got a i got
a better idea ruth
i know i agree with
ruth steakhouse i know but she's got a
bone to pick with uh with chris i i get
it and then he came back like can i get
some royalties and she's like blow me
you come stay and this is mine now you
left me in the kids so now the kids hate
him i could be butchering this whole
story but if i made a movie you know we
got to have a female lead and a female
superhero and all that [ __ ] that would
be my movie that's a badass story
critical story true yeah back there with
one hot plate making steaks for like 10
guys and the little boys are
you know they're trying to learn little
tuxedos trying to keep the place alive
crazy down in new orleans amazing queen
yeah look that up there uh man look it's
like they're so good i just hate the
name i hate the name and it's attached
to the hotel which doesn't help doesn't
help and it was just like a a party like
every we were just like come on
now did you get did you get sloppy at
all
they were i mean look we did three shows
on saturday so oh god so it's like i've
gotten good at doing starting with
coffee on that first show then
transitioning into vodka you're like you
need you need to figure that out there
is an art to that three show because i
did three that night too and you you
maybe have a beer on the first one and
the second one you're like ah give me a
vodka soda and then by the third one
you're like shot shot tequila let's do
it and then
i did one shot on stage nice the green
tea shot which is whiskey and peach
schnapps pretty solid shot not bad not
bad i don't know where you stand on that
there sloppy jalopy uh it's as far as it
tastes it's pretty good and surprising
that it actually does taste like green
tea it does um i'm a chamomile man
i like to get [ __ ] up like that's like
staten island's favorite shot really oh
really yeah like i used to work at a
like a wedding hall there and that was
like all we made as long as it's not
fireball fireball had a moment in the
sun and all that it's fizzled fireball's
a devil i don't like the devil man it's
cinnamon has no place in alcohol agreed
i'm just not like i like cinnamon i'll
be sure and i i think it has his purpose
i like big red man
yes i'll [ __ ] with cinnamon tea and fire
i'm all in
toast crunch the cinnamon toast crunch
is good best cereal i mean you're number
one i mean you're eating cubes of sugar
but it's you can't beat it give me give
me your top five sugar cereals right i
like cinnamon toast crunch i like pops
damn what pops just those yellow corn
pops are underrated i like lucky charms
weird ones all right and i like charms
oh yeah operated one too i'm eating
fruit i mean marshmallows i know
just stop just give me all marshmallows
what's with that
that's how life works you gotta have a
little struggle with your reward you're
turning this into a philosophical
conversation yeah right yeah
you gotta have a little uh a little rain
then some sunshine that's you can't just
go all sunshine
blizzard baby yeah a marshmallow
blizzard all right we got three what
else by the way ted alexandro's joke how
all the the uh horrible uh what do you
call those like traumatic what are those
called god damn it when like a hurricane
or
hurricane mudslides
natural disaster it's like the menu of
tgi friday's unleashing its wrath on the
universe that's a great joke
great joke they're all drinks hurricane
mudslide and uh the other one you said
love ted um
so uh all right yeah okay we got three
what else uh i'm blanking on a lot of
them but i'll throw froot loops in there
love fruitless love a fruit it's a
classic classic and i'm holding grams
ah
crackling oat bran oh that's that's my
number one what that's grandpa food it's
good grandpa food oat oat graham what
jaclyn oat bran mad am i crazy you guys
not doing this anything with bran i'm
out oh it's sugary though it's really
good oh okay okay
crackling oat bran is my [ __ ] that's a
game changer right there i've never even
heard of crackling oat bran you better
we're having in one of these episodes
that sounds like soul food crack when i
was growing up uh there was cracklings
what you're supposed to do with the
crackling oh brand is you take the spoon
you light a flame underneath
but uh it i like that
i think life is underrated if we're
going life is okay like okay it's not in
the top 5 but i want to give you an
honorable mention all right i'll give it
a mention i don't like the name life i
think it's too dark life sucks
life support
what else oh cap'n crunch is killer it
is good i'll tell you it does [ __ ] up
the top of your mouth it does get a
little chunky up there but captain
crunch peanut butter
and we're really going full
black tar yeah
reese's pieces came out with a cereal
and it was bananas peanut butter puffs
peanut butter puffs best cereal on the
planet that's my number one objective
damn all right so that i'm thinking what
else frosted mini wheats how do you feel
i love frosting many weeds i like how
they get a little gooey at the end i do
enjoy that i'm i'm 100 with you i just
saw a guy there's a guy in tick tock i
forgot his name he's a black guy with an
amazing voice and he just ranks food
john legend
[Laughter]
um he ranks food and he's they're funny
as hell and he does cereal and he shits
on
uh frosted mini-wheats and i i gotta go
against him on that one i love
oh really if you know that guy's name
put it in the comments cause he's so
funny he's on tick-tock he's got a huge
following he just does he just ranks
food oh okay oh you know what ain't bad
either there they are there's the
reese's is uh
smacks
also
first of all now we're talking drugs
here well i know they look like little
[ __ ] they look like little vaginas but
they're also i threw up one against my
nose
i like to run against my dick
but yeah they look like tiny clams and
uh
they taste pretty good but yeah that guy
looks like a dealer though look at him
he does he's got that frog he's just
like he's like quick pay me quick
sugar smell maybe quick are we paying
you know we forgot i'm sure we'll get
shifter for getting uh count chocolates
pretty oh yeah that's old school boy
good good call anything else we forgot i
don't i didn't like the cooking foods
honey bunch of oats is great but that's
not like the sugariest thing but it's
got sugar in it but they they play the
whole we're a health food but it's not
it's the same as life yes
life is better than that
in terms of like i think it's healthier
but no you know what they do they it's
like the kind bar [ __ ] where it's like
covered
oh yeah they're like this is a hell i'm
like it's a [ __ ] snickers dude it's a
snickers with a cool wrapper that's it
and it's called kind
wait a minute what is that one that's
got a funny name is it honey bunches of
votes there's one where it's got a funny
name and they say it in the commercial
and everybody goes ah
it's like a joke
oh
god damn it it's a funny name cereal how
do you feel on weight on wheaties
wheaties stinks it's all right it's just
cardboard with milk
i guess cardboard's okay i don't mind it
i remember when getting on a wheaties
box was a big deal if you're an athlete
like he may he got a wheaties box of
course of course bruce jenner but i
don't think if you put
uh fruit and sugar in a cereal it's
already out
i don't like when people put the like
like honey nut cheerios is good on its
own yeah but you gotta berate it you
gotta put it flakes is overrated
sucks that's just sugar in cardboard
yeah yeah they're cardboard i need sugar
on cardboard kick sucks too [ __ ] you
kicks kicks rocks
kicks yeah ki x too they thought they'd
be really hyped yeah yeah it was okay it
wasn't horrible but it was you know you
were never excited right cheerio is a
solid ah i mean you got to put oh you
got to put a strawberry in it or it's
boring that's that to me that means you
suck
you know what's interesting it's like
apple jacks apple jacks was something a
little too happily for me there was one
with a funny name that's gonna kill me
all right honeycomb no no
no sucked it's weird when uh it's you
know what's fun about the cereals though
is like you see they try to do the
different brands and stuff yeah but the
it's like cocktails the classic survive
yes you know like negroni manhattan
right but then they french toast crunch
who [ __ ] with that i tried it i had a i
had a bender on that i'm not gonna lie
to you good yeah it's pretty good i went
to vegas and it blacked out and had it
but uh it's uh it's it's okay it's
probably the most innocent vegas
blackout story ever i woke up with milk
all over me
empty bowl empty spoon
but yeah yeah dead hooker but yeah it
wasn't
oh tricks suck coco pebbles is solid
only could you get that chocolate milk
at the end yeah that chocolate milk was
a bonus for sure yeah tricks tricks
wasn't bad silly rabbit tricks are for
kids why i that was the worst worst
marketing of all time yeah what'd you
say the best milk was from the reese's
oh yeah a great meal you got great milk
butter milk
why did they ever make they made like
strawberry chocolate milk they made you
know obviously chocolate they made
vanilla where's the peanut butter
chocolate very right nesquik listen up
that's gold peanut butter milk
i just had a shake the other i'm a big
milkshake queef and i had a peanut
butter milkshake and it was dynamite is
that your go-to well i like chocolate
peanut butter mix but they don't always
have it sometimes you get a banana in
there it's kind of nice
peanut butter banana's nice i get that
my smoothie yeah which is basically a
milkshake
should we make peanut butter uh boozy
milkshakes oh don't tease me
now we're done now it's two vices now
you're hitting sugar and alcohol i feel
like a blender in a podcast
yeah right this is dangerous i'll try it
don't you just want to get to theater
level comedy where we just don't hear a
mixer in the back oh yeah that's all i
want a blender those are the best when
you're doing like a small show yeah
you're coming up 12 people in the crowd
i would kill to hear laugh over that
boom story of my life how about this one
you're doing like a good set you're
rolling here ping like ah some
[ __ ] got an email you know i
hate that there's always something with
the just the phone ringing the phone
and then no one knows who it is
everybody's doing this [ __ ]
boca raton i thought i was in a [ __ ]
real city here come on yeah yeah i had a
weird one this weekend i was in west
palm beach oh jeez that club's pretty
it's pretty nice though it's beautiful
club but here's the here's the clinker
they're short staffed every club so
every show is starting like an hour
later like what are we doing here
they're like we got eight servers and
it's five uh 500 seater i'm like oh yeah
the 430 started at 5 30. yeah
yeah
oh yeah a lot a lot of geriatrics
you gotta eat a hip crowd there though
they're they're uh no they were cool and
that little shopping center is pretty
cool yeah and i i hate the [ __ ] on
florida i love florida yada yada but
you gotta be tight and you gotta be bold
in there if you got any kind of like
smart subtle [ __ ] that's out you gotta
just
bang them over the head with something
which is it's it's horrible
but and it's an extra exercise and it's
a lot of work but it's good to like see
where your act is at
um
banger wise you know you're like that's
a banger that's a banger that ain't i
thought that was that ain't one so it's
interesting for that like leno used to
say he would follow pryor at the store
back in the day and he said i thought i
had an hour i had 20. wow because you
couldn't [ __ ] around after prior because
they just saw him
interesting yeah sometimes though i
guess it depends because we've all
followed like rock or chappelle sure and
uh
sometimes they just see the famous
person and they're like vacation is made
and they're like all right we'll give
this other guy yeah yeah some energy
because we're in a good mood now yes yes
that's true
phil hanley still has the greatest line
what do you say i mean i'm building it
up but uh it was like this is five years
ago it's louie
rock
and maybe chappelle was like some
gigantic crazy list and phil goes up
after which is always terrifying as a
young
non-famous comedian he goes
ah the big four
i think he says i'm like another one i
know oh yeah something like he's
definitely them yeah it's perfect but
yeah yeah phil's always great for his
killer zinger
so how was west palm it was good i mean
i got to tell you like that's what's so
cool about this the united states of
america is
i did a private gig in nashville
flew to nashville the day of did a great
gig for a movie festival they hired me
private gig whatever corporate whatever
you want to call it
went went out with the whole team got
drunk fell asleep woke up took two
flights connecting got all the way to
west palm and you're just in sunshine
i'm in a hotel i'm overlooking the beach
the atlantic ocean
pacific atlantic
atlantic yeah yeah atlantic and just
like oh my god it's the coolest thing
about comedy it's just like those
curtains open you're like wow this
beautiful city it's like ferrari and
maseratis going by and those cool roofs
with the the the orange uh
what do you call those
shield shillings
shingles you know there's orange that's
cool that's
i
spanish
style
called shingles i know that's also a
disease i don't know anything about cars
so it could be anything no no no i'm
talking about the the houses oh the
houses you know that spanish style
houses with like the the
give me a it's like a white kind of
that's it that's it that one right there
those shingles like all the houses look
like that it was just beautiful and
you're just like wow i'm in a whole
nother world not to mention it's [ __ ]
florida which is the you know the bath
salt of states
and uh they're all just [ __ ] wild and
everybody's having a great time and
there's iguanas everywhere and cubans
and jews and old people great time did
you see this guy on uh on tick tock
who's just knocking on really expensive
homes and he's like ah you know i just
was admiring your home how did you make
your money oh i had that exact idea did
he really do that yeah oh that was like
an idea i had but i never did it so good
for him
how does that go that's great well
people were like i uh i did all stayed
right yeah they
they they just tell him but it's like oh
it's kind of ballsy i know i had that
exact idea to just go up to you and go
how did you make your money like they
have a nice car and this guy did it
there's a guy who does that with cars as
well ah
damn it i feel like they're scripted
though cause they're always like you're
that guy from tick tock right i'm like
how do you know like i know he has a lot
of views but how do you know him like
interesting
i saw it in like a news story i didn't
see it on tick tock i just saw it like
an even bigger made it to the newest
bigger yeah you know uh although not
even bigger she's getting way more views
good point
but uh
yeah it's oh by the way i was in philly
all weekend there's a guy there's people
wearing the comedy t-shirt that you sell
all right
i'm gonna start my own i'm gonna i'm
gonna go after a joke i'm gonna go humor
i'm gonna start my own thing humor
that's great no one's taking humor
that's great although anytime somebody
refers to themselves as humorous you're
like oh you're the opposite of funny i
know you wrote a cartoon for the new
yorker in 1993.
yeah humorist
that is the opposite of
uh that's like saying is that lady
pretty she's interesting
yeah humorist is like uh
it's like pretentious but not funny yeah
yeah hold on let me get that last queef
out of there
sip it up buddy
i'm on a little muscle relaxer action so
i'm gonna try to like
oh yeah
yeah huber i like that what uh give me a
peeve
well we were talking earlier i got a
couple peeves if we really want to sink
our teeth in but
we were talking earlier like obviously
norm passing all this [ __ ] with the goat
the goat i'll post the photo you're the
goat you're the goat there's no goat
enough with the goat
you're killing that term i mean it's
like it's like we gave gold medals out
to 18 different people you know it's a
gold medal it's one guy gets it or one
gal
no enough with the goat yeah it's like
you're killing that term like it's a
goat in mexico yeah you're killing it
yeah stop killing it uh i'm with you
it's like goat for everyone it's like
goat is greatest of all time you don't
use that for everything yeah it comes
watered down completely and i think
that's kind of just how things are going
where you have to reach for the louie
had that bit where he's like he's a
genius like no no genius is this insane
level of intelligence that's very rare
and you're like you brought a cup to the
barbecue you're a genius or or that's
hilarious you know and he's like no it's
not hilarious you [ __ ] the guy's wife
it's funny but well it's like um
humorous it's like tom brady everyone's
like he's the go and you're like yeah
he's the goat but you can't use that on
other texts now
it's over exactly i'm with you i'm i'm
over goat goat enough with the goat how
about uh
how about uh
how about p p got
pretty good all time
pretty good old time
he got
pgat i know but pretty good all time
yeah in all time pretty good okay okay
okay yeah something like that or like
you know
every now and then he's de-solid
[Laughter]
e-e-n-t-s
n-e-n-t-h-s all right yeah something
like that yeah i like that people just
became obsessed with i walked by a bar
in philly called goat
everything's [ __ ] goat now it's funny
because the the goat is getting no love
it's just that term goats are still like
i'm getting [ __ ] i'm out here trying
to
farmers are [ __ ] me in the ass i'm
just trying to eat some eat some grass
sometimes i'm eating a burger i'm like
this cow is the goat yeah
yeah it's all very confusing goat cheese
isn't bad it's all right it's all right
it's overrated it's overrated like if
you're getting an omelette and they're
like it's spinach and goat cheese you
really want cheddar in there you really
do yeah yeah get out of here with the
goat cheese that's another another
overrated that could be a segment
overrated overrated i like it we might
be drunk is sponsored by better help
what's standing in the way of achieving
your goals a lot
figure it out with better help uh you
know look i've i'm in therapy it's been
very very big for me i i love it uh he's
he's definitely helped oh yeah i just
talked to him yeah yeah great guy great
therapist better help is therapy for the
21st
century better help is professional
therapy all online it's all remote do it
from the comfort and privacy of your own
home flexible schedule phone or video
calls at your convenience get a good
match they will put you with a licensed
therapist who is right for you that's
the most important part of therapy you
need someone to feel like you can talk
to them who gets you it's fast when you
sign up you can start talking to your
therapist in less than 48 hours no
waiting around it's affordable you
didn't have to be rich to pay for this
it's uh and financial aid is available
this is great and now you can send
messages to your therapist anytime paul
what about bob bill murray great movie
great movie they'll get back to you in
between sessions don't like your person
if you want to switch therapists you can
do it anytime for free trust me it helps
have someone outside your world to talk
to it's easy to schedule affordable and
will take a load of off your shoulders
over 100 over a million people have
taken charge of their mental health join
them tell them how to do it mark
better help has a special offer for our
listeners visit betterhelp.com
drunk for 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p dot com slash drunk for ten
percent off your first month
betterhelp.com drunk sign up for better
help to start living a happier life
today just try it folks you don't like
it don't keep going nate pergotzi jerry
seinfeld you're both kooks get some
therapy you chooch
what else you got
we're brought to you by sheath underwear
sheath i'm wearing it right now i think
hell yeah
nice that's it that's it hold on
up i'm wearing women's panties forget it
don't keep keep going
we love you
is the best keeps your balls off your
leg two pouches one for your dick and
one for your balls keep the ammo
separate from the gun supportive sexy
looking my girlfriend it's her favorite
underwear
how much i love mine it's crazy i love
it i love it i wear them constantly
you have your underwear that you look
forward to wearing yes and then you have
the others you're like swiss cheese on
these my balls are going to dip in the
toilet yeah i'm getting a mark uh shout
out to that classic geraldo bit
when his balls dipped in the toilet oh
yeah the idea for sheath came from its
founder us army soldier robert padden
during the second tour in iraq there's
an american hero guys hell yeah support
this awesome veteran owned company whose
founder is a big big comedy fan tell
them how to do it mark yes i love sheet
i love robert get on there go to
sheathunderware.com and order with promo
code drunk to get 20 off your first
order and sheath underwears 100 money
back guarantee that sheath underwear dot
com promo code drunk get sheet underwear
and let them support your balls
whoa
uh how about this one this is the theme
that happened to me this weekend
you ever have the guy and i'll try to
act it out
you ever heard the guy do this
do you mind if i have a sip of this and
he already told me he already took it
the guy who does the thing and then asks
if it's all right i'm guessing this
happened in nashville or florida florida
i feel like people aren't doing this
[ __ ] in new york maybe not you know the
guy was like getting like a glass out of
your cupboard he's like do you mind if i
use a glass you're like we already took
it out [ __ ] like you got to ask
before you take it out
[ __ ] is like your new insult oh
sorry
i like it i'm trying to clean it up
[ __ ] is good yeah dude i'm with you
i don't like people grabbing your [ __ ] i
feel like it's slowed down a little just
with covid like people are not as bad
but like
yeah no i'm [ __ ] that annoys me i
hate when they're doing it and they're
in the act of it and they ask if it's
all right so i'm gonna throw a blanket
over their shoulder like can i use your
blanket you're like you already already
took it
well this one's about your girlfriend
yeah
he's a blanket that doesn't make it
right
well i you know
yeah i don't like because you know i
don't like it because it's
it's just who that person is so right if
they're like the type that would just
take a sip of your thing without asking
then they're doing a ton of other
inconsiderate [ __ ] yes yes
and then they cover their ass by going
is this okay like to be polite but i
don't like a politeness if it's just a
it's just like a filler you don't mean
it you were polite after the thing it's
not polite it's not polite you're blind
yeah it's literally like cutting someone
off in traffic and being like oh do you
mind do your mind that's exactly what it
is we had a drunk driver on the road
driving back last night and it was like
[ __ ] scary he was like swerving oh
yeah that's thank god i was with gary
veeder who's like
yeah
he's like i'm gonna stay behind him i
thought we were like in french
connection for a second i'm like this is
crazy i've been on a few rides with
vitor and he gets angry he's got road
rage he's got the baby seat in the back
and he's like i'm gonna follow this like
[ __ ] this guy forget about it he swerves
in front goes to his window pulls the
guy out starts [ __ ] wailing on him
oh i got a veter story tell me if i've
told this because it's a doozy i love
you one time me and him did a gig in
like i don't know midtown and we had to
do another we were both on a show at
eastville on fourth street so we're
going midtown to downtown
we getting this uber i mean we're
getting a cab a yellow cab this is seven
eight years ago the cab was like twenty
two dollars
vitor is doing the credit card boop boop
accidentally tried to tip the guy
10 bucks tipped him a hundred bucks yeah
have i told you this i don't know but
that's i just it's happened and so the
cabbie's like he's like oh [ __ ] can you
reset it i accidentally gave you a
hundred dollars on like a 18 ride and
the guy was like i don't know how to do
i did that and the guy and vitor was
like well i'm not giving you a hundred
dollars as a tip and he's like i thought
that's how that's the machine and he was
clearly full of [ __ ] he just wanted that
money but peter's like
okay well i'm gonna sit in this cab
until you reset it or give me my money
and i'm like
dude i'm on in like two minutes we're
already at the club and he's like you
can go in
and i'm like
ah i don't want to leave my friend here
but uh so i went in did the set came
back and sat back in the cab with vito
and they're just sitting in there like
this like a mexican standoff wow or a
sit-off and eventually the guy was like
he's losing all these fares because he
could have been on driving it's been
like you know 45 minutes now so
eventually the guy was like all right
all right and he reset it wow i was like
man feeder what a badass and that is the
origin of israel and palestine
yes oh thank you oh perfect
baby
love it all right
it tastes good
um yeah dude god damn
props to vitor vito i mean
he's four foot one he's bald he's got
glasses but that guy
will take a stand he's in good shape too
he's great shape he's kind of ripped
when i met video he was a boozy pothead
and now he's like a dad in great shape
and uh just he's got like an suv he's
got a house in jersey he's really come
together i love his joke about how his
his wife caught him uh checking out
another woman she goes i i don't care
gary just don't be so obvious about it
so now i uh sit in the bushes with
binoculars
camouflage
great job he's got some of the best
classic one-liners how many guys or gals
are doing
hardcore one-liner
setup punch big laugh jokes it's pretty
rare it's rare he's old school it's like
an old-school comedy style look up veda
las vegas yes wherever you get your
comedy albums uh great out spotify
itunes uh whatever check it out he's
great banger after banger i opened for
that album we had a we had a wild week
in vegas but uh yeah killer killer out
and liz produced it damn yeah so good
shout out to liz comedy seller you she's
been getting a lot of love yeah from my
dog
you know the new york times guy jason
zimmerman wrote liz steals the whole
thing
amazing that's so great it's great made
me smile and send it to her and uh yeah
i love it i'm getting messages about the
movie so i can't imagine what you're
getting people are liking it oh yeah oh
yeah full capacity on youtube baby shout
out salaccus
uh eric scott marlon craft for the music
uh
your buddy the drum guy too he's been
killing it oh is he in it he he does the
drum set
incredible good for him that guy's great
he loves comedy he's great and who else
i mean i just want to leave anyone out
here but full capacity on youtube it's
already over 100k and it's just gonna
keep on rising it's a great time capsule
for uh you know new york city in this
weird kooky
time
harmon ryan de vere uh jason cass did
some additional editing as well uh shout
out to everyone for yeah for that josh
harmon
uh you gotta pee did we do a peeve i
gotta pee people just tell
you're either tired from work you're
tired from the energy you're tired
because you have kids
or you know you just got laid off you're
unemployed you're tired because you're
looking for work yep you're uh you're
homeless you're tired yeah because
you're homeless we're all [ __ ] tired
totally i'm 100 and everybody use that's
like a go-to excuse like get out of here
push through i want to meet the guy
who's like i'm tired but i i don't care
well i still got [ __ ] to do we're all
tired get out of here how often do you
meet a guy in new york who's like full
of energy never i never beat that guy
that's a great if you have any it zapped
you of it you you're done yeah yeah
we're all tired nobody cares you telling
me you're tired doesn't help the
situation at all so what's the point
yeah i get it it sucks we've all been
tired but
you're here so you got to do the job i'm
sorry yeah
tired good good one
we're always uh that's such a i and i i
i is a pet peeve now we're now we're
getting into a a butthole here that's my
new term for a rabbit hole because i
don't even know what a rabbit hole is so
i'm saying a butthole it's a hole for
rabbits ah
i don't know any rabbits i don't know
any rabbit holes but i know buttholes
all right all right
so
i was getting this big butthole with
somebody and
ah i forgot my point cause i'm all
excited about buttercream and a rabbit
hole in a butthole i think that's where
it's coming you don't know my friends
uh either way
i don't want any hair
all right get it hair
okay
um [ __ ] what was my point uh
butthole rabbit hole what did you say oh
uh that i'm tired tired
but you had to say nobody says we're
full of energy
oh i got it back so where i don't know
what are you 35 yeah yeah
all right 35 mid 30s i'm 38.
all these guys who go and gals who go uh
well i'll tell you nowadays uh you know
i go home at eight and i uh watch tv i
put on pajamas and i take it easy like
they're bragging about how boring their
life is that's a big thing now like i'm
not even talking about coving
pre-covered oh yeah you know me and the
lady
we call it a night at 7 30 now we're
sitting in bed reading i don't even want
to go out it's like shut up you dork get
out there come on live we're young we're
still young we're youthful 40 is the new
10.
yeah now i'm with you people that are
like really proud they're so proud i nap
four hours today how cool am i like like
you're a [ __ ] loser you nap four
hours get out of here i can't nap i
can't nap either i don't nap i coffee up
too much to nap yeah yeah and i just lay
there like
childhood you know thoughts uh this guy
hates me you know i can't nap i panic
about a lot oh yeah we're both neurotic
just thinking stewing to me a nap is a
nightmare
it's not like i can just these people
just fall asleep like oh i'm so jealous
of those people oh everyone
and the person next to you just like
conks out and you're like must be nice
must be nice then you wake up the plane
lands you're like a four-hour nap-in
plane's done i never had to worry about
the flight at all i mean jesus you guys
don't know what you have oh when when
the plane hits terrible turbulence and
the guy next to you is asleep and you're
like oh you [ __ ]
you just missed the whole event isn't
that crazy we're contemplating death
this could be it here it gets going down
and then some [ __ ] slept through
the celly flight i guarantee you
how about that guy you know just like
he's got dreams just dreaming about
rabbits going down a hole yeah
he wakes up on the hudson bay like what
happened what'd i miss
oh great we're on an inner tube what a
life
yeah
what if there's uh any other any wrecks
this week
i got my wrecks are getting weirder
because i uh
i want to branch out a little bit
here's a life hack
that someone taught me that i've never
forgotten and it's great
we go to a lot of hotels i don't know
how relatable this will be we're in a
hotel every weekend
every weekend you're in a hotel
there's an extra roll of toilet paper
under the sink in the bathroom at the
hotel
take that extra roll because you're not
going to use a whole roll wait
your wreckage to steal
yes
i'm not stealing a towel i'm not
stealing a tv
take that extra roll just sitting there
the maid doesn't notice she just goes oh
we need a new roll in here next week
mark is gonna go just go into a bank
wear a ski mask
just say give me your money they're not
using the money well you take the roll
you just put in your bag you put in your
suitcase you don't even think about it
now you're at home you get back home on
sunday or monday and you're like man
we're low on toilet paper thank god now
you've never
have to buy another toy roll of toilet
paper again because you've stolen one
way weekly
i
i mean if it works for you i've done it
for 10 years it's never failed me
you just i think you're addicted to
stealing wow this is pretty light if
we're talking stealing why it's not
getting the chair for this
yeah i should maybe i'll do it i'm just
saying it's practical they got the extra
roll it's like taking the soap you
wouldn't call that stealing would you
bad soap though it's not great soap but
i use it
i thought we're all using the soap i
mean i use it in the hotel but it's not
like
i bring it back
i'm not going full gilbert gottfried or
howard hughes here i'm just saying
there's an extra roll of charmin throw
it in the bag don't even think about it
just pick it up i think that's shitty
toilet paper too if you're in a decent
hotel they're not gonna give you the uh
the sandpaper okay the scott toilet
paper is terrible it's not great it's
just [ __ ] you gotta you gotta flip it
over five times
well what are you what are you [ __ ]
blood here i don't know i just you know
i want to make sure my finger is not
making contact with my uh with my rabbit
hole
good point that's a good point uh it's a
real briar patch down there but
we got to get a bidet that's what we're
really saying here bidet is seymour
today i know everybody got a bidet but
us bidet people send us something will
you when you're gonna pull the trigger
uh well i'll eventually kill myself but
no um i was thinking about your high
school reunion
no i think uh i think
i may want to hit my first mill if i hit
my first million i'll get a bidet how
about that all right let's make a pact
i'm all right all right we both hit a
mill
i'm gonna go to your house one day on
thanksgiving i'm gonna see you had a
bidet and i'm gonna go he made it you
could get one at 750 i think i think
you're fine they're not expensive dude
ah
it's got to be a grand with all the
money you're saving on toilet paper
that's not bad that's not bad give me a
bidet price i'm talking a decent potato
good one not one of those like 400 ones
yeah yeah yeah i'm talking a real
nothing from like afghanistan or
anything
i can't imagine they're bedeing by the
way
it's uh it's a different setting for
women
yeah it just stabs them
what um
okay so that's my that's my wreck take
the toilet paper at every hotel but it's
not relatable because not everyone's in
a hotel every weekend i think for most
people a hotel is a big deal
yeah i'm not a big uh i mean some of
these hotels i gotta get a buy out at
this point man do you feel that way too
some of them yeah really i've done it
once or twice i'm not a high maintenance
guy but uh me neither but some of them
are just crappy and you just are like
well i'm here this is quality of life
i'm on the road totally and then the
some hotels are like
30 minutes away from the club and you're
like what are you doing here yeah yeah
that's insane that's insane it's like my
half my day is getting to the club then
you get you have a few drinks you got to
get all the way back and that's ubers
and it sucks
oh wow they see these are not i'm
talking about the thing you can strap to
the toilet this is like a [ __ ] we
want a strap on mark's trying to get
pegged after [ __ ] yeah i want to get
water picked
a water peg that's a great name for a
bidet
yeah you get the freaks on board you
ever uh you ever do a water pick
what's a water pick it's basically like
a little machine that shoots water it's
flawed it's i don't think it's as good
as flossing i say it's better for you i
don't know if that's true i don't know i
did a water pick for a while and it
really gets some some chunks of
poo out of there yeah all that ass
eating i had a couple of corns and
peanuts between the molars
all right
this episode jumped this we've jumped
the shark a while ago
how about uh okay i got a wreck for you
uh how much is that
42. yeah but that can't be a good you
need a good one that is a steal
no the toilet paper is a steal yeah
sherman this is is this 42 bucks can't
be legit that is low
you got one uh i i know someone who has
one who's like it's like a heated one
too i don't need all that heat is
once you sat on a warm
like internally warm toilet seat
you won't forget it all right you don't
go back dude yeah i'm like stealing
toilet paper you're like
what do you so you think the the he the
he you recommend the heated bidet
and and how was the bidet do you feel
clean afterwards yeah it's nice the only
thing is that who i think it was like
tom segura or somebody who was talking
about he's like uh he's like a no wiper
they were talking about bert and tom
were talking about
how they both have the days they've
gotten a date to them yeah and but tom
is a no wiper
so like wow so like in italy like they
don't even have toilet paper rolls they
just have the bidet next to the toilet
yeah and then usually i don't you get up
and you just walk away with like a wet
ass i don't understand yeah i don't know
how that works i still like i'll still
like dry myself off you know yeah i mean
my [ __ ]
is it looks like sam's eyebrows it's
just covered in hair it's like a shag
carpet down there yes it tweezed the
middle of his [ __ ] just to make sure
it doesn't get any blockage going on
exactly yeah you need a bidet with like
laser
technology to like clean that area yes
yes the non-wiping is a little
ridiculous let me see this is the i i've
never done the bidet i've never either
you
you wet the butt and then you do like
one wipe so you still need some toilet
paper yeah there is so there is like a
good amount of pressure to it so it'll
like you know pierce our power wash you
out and then also they have like
circulating ones
which do a whole little like hurricane
in your butthole but aren't you a drippy
mess after that that's what i'm saying
like i like to just drive myself
there are other ones that have air that
have hot air you see now i'm in here for
20 minutes
all right what are you saying oh no i
was just saying they should make one
that has a voice with it as it's going
up your asses that you've been a very
bad boy
yeah i don't want the toilet actually i
don't want the air fryer to thing or the
dryer you know
yeah what you gotta do i do that [ __ ]
under there i don't want that on my ass
either so much stuff to look into as an
adult
it is better for the environment
using less paper paper paper paper all
day i mean years of toilet paper you've
used yeah
yeah
years like so many thousands how many
i know
noah see that one's a grand but that's a
toilet i'm talking about the the
attachment
no it's an integrated toy with
attachment
yeah i don't want the whole thing i
already got it to i live in new york my
toilet's 900 years old it's from the the
18 whatever you know tammany hall [ __ ]
on that thing do you ever think you ever
read those articles about like how rats
will run up through your toilet oh
that's rough right i remember during the
uh flood in new york you've never seen
those if you're on like a low floor
could happen so frightening it's so
frightening you'll never
not if you're richard gere
that's what i've heard he's like he's
like you're finally home
it will it will they will run out of
their articles about this in the post
and it's like i'll tell you during the
flood in new york i heard like bubbling
from my uh toilet
and my girlfriend goes what was that and
i was like nothing i swear to god the
rat was my first thought i was like
a rat just came up my toilet i'm have to
explain this one terrifying apparently
chuck berry
r.i.p
he got in trouble for putting a camera
in a women's toilet oh wow to look up
which is like
dude i get it we all like naked ladies
but uh this is the view you want you
want the [ __ ] and the perioding and
the pissing like what are you crazy well
i don't understand it was like a hidden
camera thing hidden camera and he got
busted his tv show
no no no
that's a hell of a pitch that does not
fly on abc he's like he's like guys i've
got a sales pitch for you
yeah that's the worst impractical
joker's episode yet
but no he would just he had his own
nightclub because he was a you know rich
celebrity and he put a camera in the
women's bathroom oh my god he got busted
for it but
great he went to jail i think for that
but well it's just a weird
that's what you want to see like a
dressing room okay they're women taking
their shirts off it's not the right
takeaway marcus well i'm just saying i'm
not i understand spying on women in the
shower but not in the toilet it's not
approving i'm just saying i understand
it with the toilet one you're like i
don't even understand where your head's
at maybe i mean some guys are in the
[ __ ] stuff
odell beckham whatever his name is
yeah i don't i mean it just that's crazy
there's like a law order svu about that
and you're like this is what you're i
mean that's like a dark dark
fetish right oh yeah isn't that the
german shyster films or whatever they
call where they [ __ ] on the chest and
it's it's a genre
it's not blockbuster john was a
grandiose term for the shooting
what's your favorite genre
do you like foreign films i like pooping
on the chest that's kind of my i mean
it's technically adventure
and it's a foreign adventure but yeah
that's a kyle kane joke he's like uh
he's like uh what do you you know what
were you watching i was like oh i was
catching up on some cinema it was a
foreign film russian teens you know yeah
yeah exactly che had that great joke
he's like i like to watch action films
porno i call him action film i care i'm
butchering it but uh
yeah yeah
there's [ __ ] movies out there that's all
i'm saying
should we do uh bits
yeah yeah
what's a bit you're working on all right
i got one
that uh
now these
by the way i just got to give you a uh
honorable mention your
tag you gave me or whatever your premise
or or hell the butthole thing the
butthole thing is like killing and i
i'm bittersweet cause i'm like thank you
to my friend for giving me this great
twist on the bit and also damn i wish
you wish i had thought of it you know
that feeling sure yeah yeah so it's just
it's just lights out it's like a new
banger in the bit in the act love love
having a new bit that's oh
you know i look at my act like trail mix
and you got a m m in there oh
yeah
so um
here's what i got a lot of raisins in my
new ass
yeah i got a few cashews
um so
now this is a joke i thought of two days
ago while
in the shower and i don't know if it's
anything i've never tried it on stage
never never said this out loud so this
is raw
yeah we got a new uh football player
openly gay yeah whatever his name is
quarterback i think white guy i forgot
his name what is it we need the name
but uh he's openly gay which is i think
the first nfl openly gay michael sam was
openly gay i think
was he nfl he was on the rams for a
minute i think ooh bad bad choice of
names there the ram
but uh all right
so
whatever the guy's name carl nasib
uh
so michael sam came out as gay before he
was in the nfl i think that was i think
that was it yeah yeah yeah
um cool all right so now i'm trying to
think of some other gay football names
but i can't think of any
ah
i got nothing all right so
the gay football player he's openly gay
which to me is is great and good for him
and all that but
it's impressive to me that he hid it for
so long because he was a gay player for
all these years
and
he had to tell everybody and come out
but i'm not even gay
and i've played football and got called
gay the whole time
you know i've been called uh every gay
word in the book when i have my horrible
throw
so like this guy is gay actually gay and
hid it
under the radar uh with your sexuality
and football just be really good at it
yes
yes
you know there's no homophobia when
you're [ __ ] throwing touchdowns right
right exactly yeah yeah the proof is in
the uh the anal but like
it's fascinating that he's so good at
football that no one even thought he was
gay i'm so bad at football everyone
thought i was gay and i'm not
he is gay
so and then and then also the fun idea
of this
statistically what is it one in every 10
men is gay like your old joke something
or one in every eight whatever it is so
that means we've had ton of gay players
over the years who just never came out
for sure and also uh i mean some come
out after a time it must be tough to to
have that kind of scrutiny you know when
you're when you're playing i bet it's uh
hmm
also another angle of the bit is
gay is one of the few groups like
oppressed groups that can be hidden jew
can kind of be hidden
gay can be hidden very well people gage
you very hidden very hidden yeah that's
a way in the closet
but
gay you can hide no one's ever like no
one no one ever said in the in the 50s
during segregation like i was black the
whole time you know what i mean like you
can't hide black you can hide you can't
hide um
you know
hispanic or asian you can hide gay
so there's something interesting there
like you can't know when no one on the
team was like i had no idea that guy was
uh
groups people are bigoted towards with a
with a big reveal
big reveal
gender reveal
yeah no that's true yeah
and it doesn't change anything like
they're like oh he's a gay player
whatever who cares as long as he's
making touchdowns who cares
but no one in like in the 40s in like
the school segregation was like
i tricked you i was black and i
graduated that was black
you know that could be something there
yeah though i get him like [ __ ] he is
fast that's crazy
right right yeah
i don't know it's a fun idea i'll i'll
noodle with it like how you can hide it
there's something interesting about how
it's like it's the only group that you
can kind of hide
and then i there's so many jokes about
football being super gay like they're in
the shower they're doing a huddle their
hot hut i'm like that's all been touched
it's all been done been done and i don't
i don't want to get into that world but
i feel like there's something with you
can hide it and i've been called gay and
i'm not even gay and this guy is gay
and he hasn't been called gay
he had to come out that's how good at
football he is
i'm so bad at football i'm like no no
i'm i'm straight i have to prove to them
i'm straight
you're [ __ ] a woman they're like we
still don't believe you
yeah we've seen your uh your throat
your spiral
so that's that's my idea there's
something there there's something there
i'll play with it email me if you have
any ideas by the way our fans are funny
i've gotten a few tags out of some
people oh yeah remember to email us at
we might be drunk pod at gmail.com
to uh join the patreon which is growing
patreon.com we might be drunk pod yes um
let me tell you i'm working on a couple
i don't know if i've run this on you
back in the day but i can't quite crack
it part of it's hidden hit me baby i
have a whole thing about cancelled
versus cancer
and it's kind of like cancelled versus
like cancelled
you know uh i say with cancer at least
people are rooting for you to come back
yeah like you know what i mean no one's
doing that when you're cancelled true
yeah well soon
they do that for cancer they don't do
that for cancelled right
you should get well soon right canceled
is almost like is cancer that the people
anoint you with
yeah you know the people give you cancel
life gives you cancer
yeah and it's like one of the lines that
is hidden i say um you know there's
stages for cancer there's no stages for
cancer there should be you know said
something messed up at an office party
treatable
[ __ ] the stepsister terminal oh that's
good step daughter i'll say step
daughter's better but you know what i
mean that's good yeah treatable
yeah yeah and you can get
i guess some people have gotten out of
it you can get out of can't like he's a
cancer survivor he's a cancer survivor
either way you're kind of a survivor
right yeah completely if you get out of
it
but the thing with cancer is if you
survive cancer people are like hell yeah
if you survive a cancer period like
good for you but
stay away from me or something like
there's still a little bit of residual
like i don't know about this guy we
don't see anyone who's like going
through chemo out at a restaurant like
you've got a lot of nerve showing your
face you know yeah yeah i don't know but
like yeah you almost would rather get
cancer
i wouldn't
but maybe for the bit that'd be funny
the answer's beatable
you know either way i mean either way if
you're like they find old pictures like
he had a cigarette from 1982 yeah yeah
right right yeah you see a guy smoking
like dude you gotta relax you're gonna
get cancer you see a guy um like looking
through child porn you're like dude you
gotta relax you're gonna get canceled
you know like there's symptoms there's
there's ways to get it
i don't know i don't know if i'm looking
at someone watching kitty pointing away
you gotta chill out man bad example that
exactly
uh bad example but i think i think
you're honest i i love jokes like that
that's very to me that's very carlony
you know it's like
and you get to point out things in both
i think that's i think that's big that's
like a big bit i'm gonna blow that up i
like that a lot
oh maybe there could be something with
like there's the cancer ward wouldn't
that be nice if it was a cancel ward you
know it'd be it'd be the funniest war
you're like hey look louie's here
yeah shane gillis is over here yeah
that's fun the cancel ward
oh yeah there should be different awards
yes you get you finally make it to the
worst segment you're like cosby [ __ ]
i'm not coming back from this one also
you got throat cancer you got bowel
cancer you got brain cancer there's
different kind of cancer there's 54
cancels
yeah yeah there's this
he said [ __ ] he said uh or he had
caught child porn he uh you know [ __ ]
uh 14 year old whatever it is there's
different there's different versions
yeah there's stuff other stuff to play
with here i'll take this one on the road
i love it i love it
i'm in st louis
indianapolis springfield missouri
chicago denver phoenix sf
new york coming up a lot a lot of fun
stuff dallas uh see me on the road
buffalo samurail.com shows mark where
you gonna be wait is sf back are we are
we allowed there yeah oh great all right
we got to do some of these by the way oh
shoot yeah let me let me do these before
we uh first i'll do the plugs all right
i'm all over the road i'm in nashville
this weekend zany's we're adding shows i
love zany's i love lucy i love that town
let's uh let's get cookie then we're in
uh
madison wisconsin
also adding shows love that club i've
done two albums there love those greek
ladies rochester new york hometown of
our producer matt peters i'm thinking
about doing dr grins what do you think
it's on the table
i'm putting i'm putting the pressure on
you i don't know yeah i don't know it's
it's one of those like one weekend fell
through like do you want to do dr grins
and i'm like
so
it's just your weekend yeah it's my
weekend that'll be quick and painless i
like michigan yeah michigan's cool
portland oregon and helios what happens
you got that good madcap coffee
it is that that is good coffee yeah yeah
yeah there's always a goddamn wedding in
that [ __ ] building i know laugh
boston
coming up brea improv out to the west
coast vancouver baby bc
new orleans
uh royal oak michigan again atlanta
buckhead theater and uh that'll be it
for the year so let's let's get kooky
let's say hello and let's uh let's hug
and make sure leave us a nice review on
the uh on the itunes thing sure do it up
podcast app whatever you're doing all
right
damn i had something at the end and i
forgot it
either way thanks for listening get on
the patreon we just sent out a ton of
signed postcards there's tears there's
queers there's fears horrible band from
the 80s and uh
thanks a lot praise all uh keep it
coming keep drinking
[Music]
you